Professor David Blight:
Frederick Douglass gave a
speech in 1875 that gives us a
question that we might keep in
mind right through the end of
the course.
Let's call this "Douglass's
question."
It's a speech he gives in 1875
in Washington,
D.C.
Note the year--it's 1875,
he's anticipating--it's the
4^(th) of July--and he's
anticipating the coming year of
the U.S.
centennial of independence,
and he knows it's going to be a
big national celebration;
and it will be,
and I'll say something more on
that next week.
Philadelphia put on an
extraordinary exhibition that
nearly one-tenth of the American
people visited.
But Douglass is anticipating
this national centennial,
ten years after the Civil War,
and he's worried.
He said, "The nation"--and I'm
quoting him--"would lift to the
sky its million voices in one
grand centennial hosanna of
peace and goodwill to all the
white race,
from gulf to lakes,
and from sea to sea."
And as a black citizen,
he dreaded the day,
he said--listen to his words,
it's one of the most racialized
speeches Douglass ever gave.
He said he dreaded the day
when, his words,
"this great white race has
renewed its vows of patriotism
and flowed back into its
accustomed channels."
He was proud,
he said, to be an American,
but he was worried.
And then he ended with this
question.
"If war among the whites
brought peace and liberty to
blacks, what will peace among
the whites bring?"
What would peace among the
whites bring?
It's a way of shaping an
overall question,
and Douglass did it for us,
as to how and why
Reconstruction ended up eroding,
collapsing if you want,
failing as some say--ending.
Now one of the things we're
going to begin to examine today,
and the rest of the course,
is this question--sorry to keep
putting the outline back up--but
we are always,
as historians,
debating this question of ends.
When did Reconstruction end?
As we'll see in a moment,
many are going to claim it's
all over when they pass the
Fifteenth Amendment.
That's what Horace Greeley said;
that's 1870.
And then there are those who
argue, "Reconstruction now it
really ended in 1873," and there
are reasons you might argue
that;
the horrifying Colfax Massacre
in Louisiana on Easter Sunday,
April 14^(th),
1873, the largest domestic
murder, collective mass murder
in all of American history,
until 9/11, and the following
Supreme Court decision,
based upon the investigation of
that massacre;
and I'm going to deal with
Colfax next Tuesday.
Some would argue that really
shows us an end of
Reconstruction.
But all the southern states
weren't yet back under the
control of the Democratic Party.
So there are those who argue,
"no, no, no,
Reconstruction doesn't really
end until you have the full
redemption by the Southern
Democrats of their state
governments,"
which doesn't occur until the
disputed Election of 1876,
and its compromise of 1877;
and we'll deal with that in a
week in a half.
But then there are plenty of
others now who argue,
no, no, no, Reconstruction
never really ended in the
nineteenth century.
Heather Cox Richardson has a
book out now about the story of
Reconstruction and its issues
moving west in the United
States,
throughout the rest of the
nineteenth century.
Steve Prince,
one of your teaching
assistants, has a chapter in his
dissertation entitled The Ends
of Reconstruction;
he's playing off that irony or
that pun of when did it end,
did it ever end?
Sam Schaffer's going to argue
it didn't end until 1912,
in his dissertation.
I've got another graduate
student, Owen Williams,
who's writing a dissertation on
the Reconstruction Supreme
Court,
and he's arguing it absolutely
ended in 1873.
This is the sort of inside
baseball that historians love to
play.
Name your date and then fight
over it.
We tell the world dates don't
matter, and we love to fight
over them.
I'm probably going to do what I
usually do which is leave you
with a good deal of ambiguity
about that.
In some ways Reconstruction has
never ended.
Now, think with me for a moment
though, back on the ground in
the South about this question of
the real lives of the freedmen,
the transformations to new
labor arrangements,
this vexing,
knotty, chaotic,
in some ways terrible process,
by which slave labor converted
to free labor and ultimately
into sharecropping as a system
in which approximately eighty
percent of all the freedmen
found themselves essentially
mired in,
as early as the late 1860s and
surely by the 1870s and
throughout the rest of that
century.
One of the greatest memoirs we
have--it's an odd kind of
memoir--but one of the greatest
memoirs we have by a
sharecropper--and I don't know
if you've ever read this book in
a course,
it gets widely taught,
often in African-American
history courses--is the
autobiography of Nate Shaw
called All God's Dangers.
His real name was Ned Cobb;
name was changed,
I guess to protect him,
in the title.
It's an extraordinary series of
hundreds of hours of interviews
that Ted Rosengarten did with
him some 25 years ago now.
Ned Cobb lived a very,
very long life,
into the middle of the
twentieth century,
but he grew up a sharecropper.
And there are a thousand
nuggets of wisdom,
or the secrets from his past,
as he often calls them,
that Ned Cobb/Nate Shaw has to
give us.
There's this honest section
about how he never got an
education, and how he resents
that he never got an education,
and how he resents actually
that his father never even
sought to help get him an
education.
"I didn't never get out of the
first reader.
Got no education to speak of,
and another hurt addition to
that, weren't no colored schools
through here"--and this is
central Alabama--"worth no
count.
You might find a school close
to town somewhere that
accommodated the colored,
and if you did you were doin'
well," said Ned.
"My daddy, when he had the
opportunity, never did send me
to school long enough to learn
to read.
If he sent his children he'd
have to supplement the teacher's
salary, but if he don't send his
children it don't cost him
nothin',
and there's nothin' said.
None of my brothers and
sisters, not one by name,
got a good book learning,
and all I can do,
I can put down on paper some
little old figures but I can't
add 'em up."
Now, Ned went on to be a land
owner.
One of the most moving passages
in this book comes toward the
end when he buys his first mule,
when he puts his first
stinking, smelly mule in his own
stable.
It's like a religious
experience.
Smelling a mule is not exactly
my idea of a religious
experience, but it was to Ned.
But he really is hard on his
father.
It's an honest,
honest illustration of how the
sons and daughters of the
freedmen--and Ned is the son of
a former slave--were inheriting
so little.
I mentioned the other day that
what the freedmen had was some
human capital,
their skills,
their bodies,
their labor,
their dreams,
their religion,
their ideas,
their self-worth,
their dignity,
but they had so little physical
capital, they owned nothing,
and they had no money,
no credit, so few ways of
getting any physical capital.
He goes on and on and on.
I won't quote it but he
continually refers to what he
called his father's "old slavery
thoughts."
He complains about how his
father never learned how to put
up any money,
never learned to save anything,
and that he hadn't learned it
very well either.
In fact, here's what he says.
He said, "My daddy was
blindfolded, didn't look to the
future, just throwing"--I'm
sorry for the direct language
here--"just throwing his money
in a dead hog's ass and taking
shit."
Sorry about that, on the video.
But Ned Cobb's directness is
useful.
It's in the face of those kinds
of obstacles,
we can tamely call them,
but nevertheless thousands upon
thousands of freedmen embraced
an education and embraced the
hope that literacy could bring.
And let me focus on that,
just briefly at least.
Mired in this system of
sharecropping,
working on halves,
giving half their crop to the
landowner and half their crop
they would keep and hopefully
get cash,
but then that cash had to be
spent down at the furnishing
merchant to get seeds and get
tools and get food and clothing.
Nevertheless,
in the face of all of this,
one of the things a freedman
most wanted was this book
learning that Ned Cobb never
got.
What we know about slave
literacy and freedmen's literacy
is essentially this.
At the end of the Civil War
probably five percent,
maybe seven percent to eight,
of the American slaves were
literate.
By 1870 that had increased to
perhaps twelve to fifteen
percent, and that was due,
of course, to the freedmen's
schools, to the Freedmen's
Bureau schools.
There were tremendous
accomplishments in these
Freedmen's Bureau schools.
They created over 4000 of them,
and there were some 9300
teachers at one time or another
employed in Freedmen's Bureau
schools, up into the 1870s.
They had at one point slightly
more than a quarter million
students in these schools,
freedmen, young and old;
sixty-eight,
seventy-two year-old former
slaves would sit down in the
same room with eight year-olds
and begin to try to read out of
the same reader.
And there were in some ways
nothing more threatening,
to white Southerners--actually
there were two things most
threatening to white
Southerners,
around which this Southern
counter-revolution will be
forged.
One was the black school,
black literacy,
education, the potential of
mobility, and the education
particularly of a black
political leadership class.
And then on the other hand,
directly related,
of course, was the creation of
black politics itself.
As we'll see in a moment,
one of the major targets of the
Ku Klux Klan,
the Knights of the White
Camellia,
and all the other groups that
imitated these,
were black schools.
Dozens and dozens of black
schools were burned to the
ground by the Klan between 1868
and the middle of the 1870s.
I want to just read just one
little example of what these
schools meant to people.
I love this little letter
because of the assumption,
let's call it audacity of hope
if you want--forgive the title.
This comes from a black school
principal whose name was P.B.
Randolph.
He's running a Freedman's
school in New Orleans,
in 1866.
They named it for William Lloyd
Garrison, it's called the
Garrison School.
He has 373 pupils and he has
seven teachers,
five of them black,
two of them white.
And this was the revolution,
the potential revolution of
Reconstruction.
And he writes this letter to
himself, William Lloyd Garrison,
asking for Garrison to help
them get what they need.
Just a small excerpt of it.
"We are proud of our pupils and
feel you will rejoice with us.
We feel also that you will not
take amiss if we ask a little
assistance from Boston in the
shape of apparatus to illustrate
astronomy,
a gyroscope and a microscope,
a numerical frame,
conic sections,
cube root blocks,
a magnet, and such other
instruments as will enable us to
fight this battle for our race
against ignorance."
Send us the simplest implements
to teach some science.
There are thousands of those
such letters all over the
record.
Literacy among blacks increased
to over eighty percent by
1880--I'm sorry,
over twenty percent by
1880--and probably twenty-five
to thirty percent-- these things
are very difficult to
measure--by the turn of the
twentieth century.
Now you need to know one other
thing here.
By the 1880s,
1890s, turn of the twentieth
century, literacy rates among
southern whites were not that
much higher.
Now remember one thing above
all else about these new
economic, social arrangements
taking hold from 1866 right on
through the 1870s in the South.
Sharecropping emerged--this is
the argument--sharecropping
emerged essentially as a kind of
compromise result of a
tug-of-war between two kinds of
interests.
Blacks wanted autonomy.
They wanted out of gangs.
They wanted their women out of
the field.
They wanted some control over
their economic lives.
White folks,
the owners, land owners,
wanted labor control,
a stationary,
dependent, poor labor force.
Both sides end up embracing
tenant farming,
sharecropping,
because it was such a
desperately cash poor society.
Land owners didn't want to rent
to blacks because they knew in
the long run blacks wouldn't get
enough cash to pay the rent.
Blacks realized quickly they
couldn't depend on cash because
there wasn't enough.
They therefore themselves began
to resist wages,
because they'd get promised
wages and then they wouldn't get
paid.
So sharecropping,
this system that ultimately
becomes a Faustian bargain and a
dead end and a kind of tragic no
exit for the vast majority,
was nevertheless something they
actually negotiated and embraced
themselves.
Now, also on the ground,
in the South,
emerging, out of Radical
Reconstruction,
as the Southern states were put
under the First Reconstruction
Act and the subsequent
Reconstruction Acts,
what took place in the South
was the creation of new state
governments run by the
Republican Party in every former
Confederate state,
at least at first.
All the ex-Confederate states
were readmitted to the Union
between 1868 and 1870;
Georgia was the last.
But by 1870 all eleven
ex-Confederate states are back
in the Union.
But they're back in the Union,
remember, under that Radical
Reconstruction Plan.
Now the story that set in about
this, over the years,
from the Lost Cause ideology of
the late nineteenth century to
the writings of the so-called
Dunning School at the turn of
the twentieth century and early
twentieth century,
based on the writings of
William H.
Dunning and his many,
many students he trained at
Columbia University,
was this idea that what
happened in the South now was
essentially carpetbag rule,
or rule by bayonet,
or rule by blacks.
Now in the history books we've
come to call this,
for decades,
the myth of carpetbag rule,
this idea that the South was
colonized, taken over by
Northerners who moved south,
white Northerners who moved
south, applying,
appealing to,
exploiting and manipulating the
black vote to take over the
South,
to disfranchise and eliminate
white Southerners from their own
polity.
Now this much is true:
In every former Confederate
state the so-called radical
constitutions did manage to
create all sorts of new levels,
if you like,
of democracy,
small-"d".
The number of elective offices
increased.
There was more direct election,
more direct control for people
than the South had ever seen.
There were more people voting,
more constituencies,
and more people holding office,
as we'll see in a second.
There was more home rule for
local governments than they'd
ever experienced before.
These new radical
constitutions,
yes indeed, had eventually a
fair degree of corruption.
This was the age of spoils and
the kinds of corruption going on
in southern state governments
was no different than the kinds
of corruption going on in many
other places in the country.
But there were many social
provisions in these new
constitutions,
as long as they lasted.
And they lasted seven,
eight and nine years,
in some ex-Confederate states,
and they only lasted two,
three, and four years in
others.
For the first time there were
social provisions.
They not only did away with the
Black Codes but they established
a certain degree of equal civil
rights.
Some of these new state
governments actually passed
Civil Rights Acts.
Many of the constitutions made
it the state's responsibility
now to--for the first time in
Southern history;
and for that matter there
wasn't much of this in the North
either--to provide for the sick,
the insane, the disabled,
the poverty stricken.
And above all else they created
public schools,
the first public schools the
South had ever seen.
South Carolina had the first
comprehensive school law of any
southern state,
passed in 1870.
By 1871 they had thirty-two
percent of people of school age
attending some 1700 public
schools, in South
Carolina--blacks and whites.
And by 1875 the South Carolina
public school system,
created by the Radical
Republican regime,
had fifty percent--this is
still a rural society and a
society ridden with problems of
race and violence,
as we'll see--by 1875 they had
fifty percent of the school age
population of South Carolina in
school,
with over 3000 teachers paid by
public tax money.
Now, the one thing,
of course, that virtually no
southern, Radical Republican,
southern regime ever
accomplished was much in the way
of any kind of economic
redistribution,
of land redistribution.
This is our classic problem of
Reconstruction.
How could you advance political
liberty, the right to vote,
to hold office,
serve on juries,
run legislatures,
and yet why does economic
liberty always,
always, always lag behind?
Now, there were some attempts,
however.
Let me give you just one little
example.
I don't think Foner really even
mentions this.
Again, South Carolina,
which had a black majority of
its legislature for about five
years during
Reconstruction--this was
political revolution,
and you can see why white
Southerners were organizing
against it--but the South
Carolina Legislature,
run by blacks,
by blacks and white
Republicans, some of them native
born Southerners,
some of them from the North,
created a South Carolina Land
Commission.
They created it in 1868.
It actually is going to last
all the way to 1890,
on the books.
It settled some 5000 South
Carolina families,
black and white,
on land that the state
purchased,
or took over--confiscated--in
effect, and then began to sell
to its own citizens on long-term
loans,
at very reduced interest rates.
Approximately $225,000 out of
$802,000 eventually could not be
accounted for.
There was some fraud and
corruption in this South
Carolina Land Commission.
About a quarter of the money
that they actually distributed
never was accounted for.
But it's extremely important to
note here that at least an
attempt was made.
Here was at least the
possibility of Radical
Reconstruction.
By 1876 that Land Commission in
South Carolina--by '76
Republicans still barely
controlled the South Carolina
state government,
they're about to lose it that
year--by 1876 about 14,000
families had participated,
a total of about 70,000 people,
about sixty percent black and
forty percent white,
in actually buying land.
By 1884 more blacks were losing
land in South Carolina,
however, than were buying it.
I'll give you one last little
number to show at least what the
possibilities had been.
In the Census of 1890 about
13,000 blacks in South Carolina
owned a farm of some size,
4,000 of whom had purchased
them through that Land
Commission.
Now, we are always talking
about the possibilities,
the experiments of
Reconstruction--"what if," "what
if," "what if?"
What if there'd been more
enforcement?
military occupation?
What if the Klan and its
imitators had truly been
crushed--altogether crushed?
This kind of land commission is
one example, among others,
of the kinds of efforts that
could have flourished.
Now, in those state governments
in the South,
you had for the first time in
American history,
and in a kind of a explosion of
political activity,
you had black elected
officials;
approximately 200
African-Americans in the
Southern states served in state
legislatures,
in state government and
executive positions,
and ultimately in the U.S.
Congress.
Sixteen African-Americans from
ex-Confederate states were
elected to the U.S.
Congress, two to the U.S.
Senate--Hiram Revels from
Mississippi being the first
black senator in American
history.
And how many times do you hear
in our political culture today,
"the first black since
Reconstruction;
the first this since
the first that--."
The first black governor since
Reconstruction was Doug Wilder,
in Virginia.
The first this and the first
that, since Reconstruction.
It's because there was this
explosion of black political
activity, for a short period of
time, a decade really,
until the lights went out.
Of the 1000 delegates to
Constitutional writing
conventions, in 1868,
'69, when these new state
governments were created,
of about the 1000 delegates
that participated in writing
those new Constitutions,
268 of them were black.
About 680 African-Americans
served in the lower houses of
state governments during
Reconstruction.
Four presided as speakers of
those houses.
There were 112
African-Americans who served in
State Senates during
Reconstruction.
There were at least 41 black
sheriffs, somewhere in one of
the eleven ex-Confederate
states.
There were five black mayors of
Southern cities,
for awhile.
There were 145 blacks who
served on city councils,
and so on and so on.
Now this is the heart of the
myth of carpetbag rule.
The claim against these people,
in the South at least,
in the white South,
was always they were not
prepared,
they were ignorant,
all they did is sit around
eating chicken bones and
spitting into gold spittoons
that they bought with public
money.
And if you've ever seen
Birth of a Nation,
D.W.
Griffith's white supremacist
epic of 1915,
he plays out that scene at
great length of the black
politicians in state
legislatures with their boots up
on tables,
literally chewing on chicken
bones and spitting into
spittoons and laughing and
playing happy darkie,
until the cows come home.
Now there were corrupt black
politicians and there were
corrupt white politicians.
I don't really have time to go
into all the great biographical
stories of the Robert Smalls'
and the John Roy--the Robert
Smalls' of South Carolina and
the John Roy Lynch's of
Mississippi,
and so many others,
many of whom were former
slaves, although some of them
had been free before the war,
by their own purchase,
by manumission,
by other means.
Some of them,
only a small percentage,
were northern-born blacks who
moved south, like Hiram Revels,
and eventually got himself
elected to the Senate.
By the way, just recently--well
I guess it was about eight years
ago--when the Republicans had
control of the Senate they put
up a portrait,
for the first time,
of Hiram Revels;
our modern Republican Party
wanted to claim him.
He was a Republican;
so were they, by name.
But anyway there is now today a
portrait of Hiram Revels.
It took a century,
more, to get it there,
but he's finally up in the U.S.
Senate, his picture.
Now the other side of this myth
of carpetbag rule--and I want to
be a little speedy about this,
but it's also very
important--again,
the story, the deep myth that
set into American culture for
generations is that all these
Reconstruction governments
really were a bunch of Yankees
who came south,
got themselves elected with
black votes and ran these
governments and oppressed white
Southerners.
So who were these
carpetbaggers,
so called?
The term got into our language,
and now today anybody who grows
up in one state but somehow
moves to another and tries to
get elected,
as Hilary Clinton did in New
York, and there are plenty of
other examples,
is labeled a carpetbagger,
at least for ten years or so,
until she's lived there long
enough and gets reelected and I
guess--I guess you got to get
reelected before you're no
longer a carpetbagger.
Well, many of these Northerners
who went south were former Union
soldiers.
Most of them went before 1867
and '68, before these Radical
Republican regimes were put in
place.
They went to become farmers.
They went because the land was
so cheap.
And some of them went because
they liked the climate.
There were New Hampshirites who
went to Mississippi because it
was warm.
Some carpetbaggers were
industrialists and investors.
They saw the South now as the
place to invest.
It obviously was.
It was prostrate,
and it needed money.
Some were federal agents,
Freedmen's Bureau agents who
stayed and lived there.
Many were teachers,
some who stayed and lived,
if they survived and weren't
killed.
Some were political
opportunists and some were
adventurers and n'er-do-wells.
And I'll never forget,
as long as I live,
one of the best friends I have
in the world is a Methodist
minister in Chicago who grew up
in Mississippi and East Texas,
Gene Winkler,
and a positively--he's one of
the best read human beings I've
ever known.
He reads more about the Civil
War than I do.
I used to actually ask him what
I should be reading.
His real job is being a
minister but he spent most of
his time reading.
And he was one of the most
politically radical people I've
ever known.
He was still trying to be a
socialist during Reaganism.
But one day I asked Gene,
"Gene, why do you keep that
picture of Stonewall Jackson and
Robert E.
Lee in the corner of your
office?"
He said, "You know,
I'm not exactly sure.
It's probably because
carpetbaggers killed my
great-granddaddy."
[Laughter]
I don't think he said god-damn
carpetbaggers;
he's a good Methodist.
"Carpetbaggers killed my
great-granddaddy."
I said, "Oh, oh okay."
[Laughter]
Like so many Southerners,
he was a complicated mixture of
memories and--well enough on
Gene.
I actually got the thrill some
years ago to write an essay,
epilogue to Fitz Brundage's
book of essays called Where
These Memories Grow,
about southern memory,
and I opened the piece with
that very story,
and I was always worried about
how Gene was going to interpret
it.
And he, thank God,
liked it, I think.
Anyway.
At no time did carpetbaggers
ever make up anywhere near a
majority of any southern
legislature in the
ex-Confederate states.
Their goals tended to be
financial, economic,
and to some extent political.
And then there's this other
kind of Southerner,
the white indigenous
Southerner,
the native born white
Southerner, known to history,
of course, as Scalawags,
who joined the Republican
Party, who became part of these
Reconstruction regimes,
who said give up the past,
give up the old cause,
and they often became the
object of the ire and the hatred
and the violence of white
vigilante groups,
as readily as anyone else.
Now what was a Scalawag?
Let me tell you the ways.
Hold on, sorry,
forgive me, got it.
So a Scalwag is,
by the way, a runty little
horse--that's actually what it
means if you look it up--it's a
runty little horse,
a kind of useless little horse
that doesn't work very well for
you, just gets in the way,
stinks and smells and doesn't
pay his way.
"Our Scalawag is the local
leper of the community," wrote a
Tuscaloosa, Alabama newspaper
editor in 1869.
"Unlike the carpetbagger he is
native, which is so much the
worse.
Once he was respected in his
circle, his head was level,
and he would look his neighbor
in the face.
Now, possessed of the itch of
office and the sought room of
radicalism, he is a mangy dog,
slinking through the alleys,
haunting the governor's office,
defiling with tobacco juice the
steps of the capitol,
stretching his lazy carcass in
the sun on the square or the
benches of the mayor's court."
That's relatively direct.
Scalwags were considered,
in other words,
turncoats.
Now, they had a variety of
social backgrounds.
Some were sort of former
nobodies but most of them were
actually quite prominent people,
like the wartime Confederate
Governor of Georgia,
Joseph E.
Brown, who said "give up the
cause," and joined the
Republican Party after the war.
Perhaps most famous of all,
James Longstreet,
Lee's second in command in the
last two years of the war,
Longstreet of Georgia,
moved out to Louisiana after
the war, embraced the Republican
Party,
said the war had settled
something and Southerners had to
face it.
And he became a railroad
president.
And he even for awhile
commanded U.S.
troops in Louisiana who tried
to kill off the Klan.
There are many,
many other examples.
There's James Settle of North
Carolina.
He's one of my favorites.
These were fascinating people,
courageous people.
Settle of North Carolina had
been a member of the Confederate
Congress.
He'd been a big player in
Confederate politics in North
Carolina, but after the war he
said this.
"The war had brought a general
breaking up," he said,
"of old ideas.
Taking a new start in the world
we are, if we are ever to have
prosperity."
And then he concluded,
"I tell you,
Yankees and Yankee notions are
just what we want in this
country now.
We want their capital to build
factories and workshops and
railroads.
We want their intelligence,
their energy and enterprise to
operate factories and to teach
us how to do it."
Settle nearly was killed for
his views, his actions;
his political actions in
particular.
There are many other examples.
Amos T.
Akerman in Georgia,
among others--look up him in
Foner if you like.
Now I guess the only other
thing I want to say about that
is there were carpetbag
governors.
There were northern born
Republicans who ended up
governors of southern states,
several of them.
There were northern born
members of southern state
legislatures,
some black,
some white, and they became,
in many instances,
the most ready targets of what
was to come.
Now, I don't now how well you
can see this painting,
I'll try to blow it up.
It doesn't have a date on it,
unfortunately.
I need to figure that out.
It is entitled
"Disfranchisement," which is an
interesting title.
If you can see on the right,
you can see about every kind of
image of a bitter,
angry, hate in the eyes,
Southerner, some sitting on the
cannon, others in Ku Klux Klan
robes and masks,
all of them,
of course, looking at the lone
black freedman,
who on your first look almost
looks like he's holding a
machete,
but he's not,
he's holding a voting roll.
Now, the southern white
counter-revolution,
the move towards southern
redemption,
which simply means,
of course, the southern
Democratic Party taking back
control of their states,
between 1870 and 1876,
is rooted in their hatred,
their resentment of the rise of
black political and economic
independence.
Now, but first of all,
go with me back to Washington,
and then we'll end,
at least today,
back on the ground in the South
and try to understand where some
of this violence is coming from.
The Fifteenth Amendment passed
Congress, the Fifteenth now,
passed Congress in the spring,
late spring,
of 1869.
It's right after Ulysses S.
Grant is inaugurated president.
He's elected in the fall,
inaugurated in the spring.
By 1868, eleven of the
twenty-one northern states still
denied the right to vote to
blacks.
You'll remember,
Republicans are stepping around
this question of black suffrage
in the North,
but they want to plant it into
the South.
But the trick was,
what kind of amendment would it
be?
This is the great Voting Rights
Amendment.
They went through three
versions of the Fifteenth
Amendment--look this up in
Foner,
make sure you understand
it--they went through three
versions in the debate in
Congress as to what kind of
voting rights amendment to put
in the Constitution.
The first version--and they
went from most conservative to
most radical--the first version
forbade states the right to deny
suffrage on grounds of race,
color or previous condition of
servitude;
that's all it said.
That's the most conservative
version.
The second version would've
forbade states to impose
literacy, property or nativity
qualifications;
in other words,
that whole array of
qualifications tests that will
ultimately be used,
all over the South,
to prevent black folk from
voting;
and to some extent poor white
folk.
And then there was a third
version which simply would've
affirmed simply that all male
citizens twenty-one years of age
and older had the right to vote,
period.
Now, they debated and debated
but the one they passed,
of course, was the first one,
the most conservative,
the one that made absolutely no
mention of the possibility of
qualifications tests.
And so the Fifteenth Amendment
has two kinds of impact,
two great importances if you
want.
One is that it was passed at
all, and it's hugely important,
but the other,
of course,
is it was a very conservative
compromise amendment that left
the door open to all kinds of
machinations,
over time, in states,
at the local level,
about qualifications to vote.
It passed the House of
Representatives in March,
1869.
It finally was ratified by
two-thirds of the state
legislatures in the United
States, a full year later,
in the spring of 1870.
And many people now looked at
the situation in the country,
a year into Grant's presidency,
the man, the Republican,
who said, "Let us have peace."
You've got the Thirteenth
Amendment abolishing slavery.
You got the Fourteenth
Amendment establishing
citizenship rights and equal
protection before the law;
at least the beginnings of this
fledgling thing called civil
rights.
You got the Reconstruction Acts
in place.
Southern states have all been
brought back into the Union,
by 1870--only Georgia was still
being sort of weirdly
adjudicated,
but it finally was brought back
in, in 1870.
And now comes the Voting Rights
Act.
And throughout the history of
modern political philosophy and
modern political history,
the idea was that the vote was
the essence of democracy.
And so once you've given people
the vote, on some level what
else could you possibly do?
Republicans themselves now say,
to themselves,
that they have established the
principle-- oh,
would that they had--of
guaranteed rights,
and that they could go no
further.
One Republican wrote to
another, after voting for this,
he said, "This is," quote,
"the last great point that
remains to be settled from the
issues of the war."
And Horace Greeley famously,
in his New York Herald
Tribune, in April 1870,
after the ratification of the
Fifteenth Amendment,
said, quote,
"Let us have done with
Reconstruction"--it was the
opening line under a big
headline--"Let us have done with
Reconstruction.
The country is tired and sick
of it.
Let us have peace."
"It's over, it's done," said
official Republican Party people
to themselves.
And of course the white South,
for two years already,
through its rising and growing
Democratic Party and its violent
militant wings,
is saying, "You bet
Reconstruction is over.
Let us show you the ways."
Now, I'm actually going to save
the violent story for an entire
lecture on its own;
the Klan, its many actions,
examples, through the Colfax
Massacre, at least,
of 1873, for next Tuesday.
But let me leave you with this.
What happens now,
what is already happening now,
in the first Grant
administration,
by 1870, is what we might
simply call--it's the waning of
Radicalism, it's the waning of
that civic vision,
as Foner calls it in your book,
of the Radical Republicans'
ideology.
And what was that vision?
Foner lays it all out for you.
He said the Radical Republicans
had an essential ideological
vision.
On the one hand it was Unionism.
On the other hand it was
rooted, to some extent,
in trying to create racial
equality, because the war had
necessitated,
it had forced it on them.
They, therefore,
were believers in this idea of
guaranteed rights within the
Constitution.
And last but not least they
were believers in positive
activist central government.
And you put those three or four
principles together and you've
got the package that was the
civic vision of the Radical
Republicans.
But the problem is that vision
is now going to crumble as fast,
almost as fast,
as it ever came into existence;
in fact, it's going to crumble
faster than it ever came into
existence.
Oh I'll leave you with this.
It's not just going to crumble
because Republicans sort of give
up the game,
and it's not going to just
crumble because Thaddeus
Stephens dies and Charles
Sumner's out of the way,
and Radicals don't really run
this party under Grant anymore.
It's going to crumble because
of the most widespread use of
political violence in American
history.
We'll return to this question
next Tuesday,
but let me leave you with this.
There is no African-American
writer, and some white writers,
worth their salt,
from the 1870s and '80s,
right on through well into the
twentieth century,
who could ever avert their eyes
from this story.
This is a passage from James
Weldon Johnson's The
Autobiography of an
Ex-Colored Man.
If you've ever read that
wonderful 1912 novel,
you'll know it's the story of a
black man who's passing for
white,
but because he's passing in the
South he gets to see things that
people don't know he's seeing.
And of course the book ends,
as so many books did in this
time, with a lynching.
This is Ex-Colored man--he
doesn't have any other
name--describing what he sees.
"A railroad tie was sunk into
the ground.
The rope was removed and a
chain brought and securely
coiled around the victim and the
stake.
There he stood,
a man only in form and stature.
His eyes were full and vacant,
indicating not a single ray of
thought.
Fuel was brought from
everywhere;
oil, the torch,
the flames crouched for an
instant as though to gather
strength, then leaped up as high
as the victim's head.
He squirmed,
he writhed, he strained at his
chains, then gave out cries and
groans that I shall always hear.
His eyes, bulging from their
sockets, rolled from side to
side, appealing in vain for
help.
I was fixed to the spot where I
stood, powerless to take my eyes
from what I did not want to
see."
We have never wanted to see
what really happened in the
South, in the 1870s,
but we'll try.